not a day goes by without the internet
nearly shutting down completely over a
breaking news story
the most recent threat of total
implosion came on May 16th when word got
out that Warner Brothers and director
Matt Reeves were nearing a deal with
Robert Pattinson to become the new
Batman taking over for Ben Affleck even
though Pattinson has been in plenty of
films most only know him from his role
as the glistening vampire Edward Cullen
in the Twilight film saga so to imagine
him donning the cape and cowl and Reeves
the Batman was simply too much for
people
Pattinson fans those who aren't down for
the English actor to portray the famous
superhero and everyone in between is
completely freaking out about his
reported casting one person tweeted it
is official the DCE you should be
canceled this is a horrible choice to
play the character someone else
practically shouted into the
Twittersphere when Pattinson 'he's name
started trending on the site Robert
Pattinson getting casted proves the DC
Comics the DC Universe Warner Brothers
hates its fans awful just awful I've
never been so disappointed in a Batman
casting dammit
anger over Pattinson assuming the bat
mantle from Affleck got so intense that
naysayer started various online
petitions demanding that Warner Brothers
and Reeves replace the actor with
someone else at the end of the day it's
unlikely that any of the appeals will
amount to much more than extra Internet
noise Bruce Wayne why you dressed up
like Batman the other side of social
media couldn't be happier about
Pattinson lining up to become the new
Batman and have some advice for those
who were criticizing the casting choice
two years ahead of the film's June 2021
release date one user posted on Twitter
Robert Pattinson is the perfect casting
for Batman another fan rallying behind
Pattinson appointed to the actors work
outside of the Twilight franchise as
evidence that he can deliver an
incredibly powerful performance and will
likely do the same when it comes to
Bruce Wayne and the Batman Robert
Pattinson playing Batman sounds awesome
the man truly proved himself as a
wonderful performer in these few years
and I'm certain he'll play the part well
a Twitter user by the name of Josh price
also urged though skeptical about
Pattinson z' ability to give a solid
performance as Batman to check out the
actors post Twilight movies namely good
time' Cosmopolis and the road
he wrote if you're in any doubt over
Robert Pattinson being cast as Batman
because you only know him from Twilight
then please watch these three movies
then try to tell me he isn't an amazing
choice Eisner award-winning comic book
writer and Hugo Award nominated novelist
Saladin Ahmed gave a tongue-in-cheek
response to the uproar in a post shared
to his Twitter page
a man pointed out the irony and the fact
that many of the people mad about
Pattinson portraying Batman are
apparently failing to remember how
inherently silly the costumed vigilante
really is a med tweeted ugh
they picked an angsty pretty boy who
spent his early 20s pretending to be a
vampire I have bad news for you about
Batman Joe Blow editor-in-chief Paul
Shirey had arguably the most pragmatic
reaction to all the hullabaloo he
reminded everyone that three previous
Batman actors Affleck Christian Bale and
Michael Keaton starred in their fair
share of soso films before they became
Batman some of them were downright goofy
in Shirey sighs people should engage
Pattinson Zack ting ability solely on
Twilight as they wouldn't judge Affleck
Keaton or Bale on their wackier pre
Batman works the best thing is just to
withhold extreme judgments one way or
the other about Pattinson succeeding
Affleck as the Caped Crusader until the
Batman hits theaters in 2021 hopefully
once the Batman gets closer to its
premiere date the Pattinson lovers and
the Pattinson haters can settle their
differences and a general consensus
about the situation can be established
for now keep it civil remember Gotham's
watching check out one of our newest
videos right here plus even more looper
videos about superhero movies are coming
soon subscribe to our YouTube channel
and hit the bells so you don't miss a
single one
[Music]